NARRATOR: Life on
Earth seeded from Mars?
Could we in fact be Martians?
Ancient astronaut
theorists say yes,
and suggest that
this seeding of earth
may even have been
a directed effort
orchestrated by
human-like beings
that existed on the red planet.
And they claim these extra
terrestrial ancestors
can be found in the apocryphal
texts of the Hebrew Bible,
represented as
the fallen angels.
We know from ancient
legend, of the books of Enoch,
that there was a group of
angels who descended to earth
in violation of divine law.
They introduced to
humanity ways, means,
knowledge, which we
would understand today
as science and technology.
These angels were in human form.
They were called in Hebrew
[hebrew],, which means men.
They looked just like us.
JONATHAN YOUNG: The
fallen angels were giants.
They were at least 10 feet
tall, very striking to look at,
enormous eyes, and no wings.
WILLIAM HENRY: For
over 100 years,
mythologists have
been contemplating
this idea that the fallen
angels came from Mars to Earth.
Even Dante described
this in the "Paradiso."
He called this the
fifth level of heaven.
Is it possible that the fallen
angels came to Earth from Mars?
NARRATOR: Could we reinterpret
the story of fallen angels
as beings not from
heaven, but from Mars?
Based on examination of
the astronauts living
in the International
Space Station,
scientists have
speculated on what
physiological changes might
be seen in future generations
of humans born on Mars.
And ancient astronaut
theories suggest
the resemblance to the
description of fallen angels
may be uncanny.
SUE ANN PIEN: One
of the most amazing
things about the human body
is its ability to adapt.
And if you look at
astronauts who go into space,
they actually grow about
two or three inches.
And when you have a human
that's born on Mars, what's
going to happen
is the environment
will change the structure
of the human body.
And what you're going to
see in a few generations
is humans that are
taller and skinnier,
because the gravity on Mars
is less than that of Earth.
MIKE BARA: If humans evolve
long enough on the planet Mars,
they could grow to be taller,
they'd have the bigger heads,
they'd have the spindly limbs.
They might actually grow
slightly larger eyes that
were equipped to see
better in the dark,
because you simply have
less sunlight on Mars
than you do on the
Earth, because it's
farther away from the sun.
They could also end up looking
like representations of angels
and various other
godlike beings that we've
read about in the Bible and
other ancient documents.
DAVID CHILDRESS: These
attributes to somebody
from a low-gravity
planet like Mars,
or being in space
for a long time,
may well be the attributes that
we see of the fallen angels
being very tall and
spindly, and perhaps pale,
and with large eyes.
Something that we might
expect to be coming
from another planet like Mars.